As the day cools down, life slowly returns
to the bush in south-east Zimbabwe.
The African wild dogs spent the hottest part
of the day sleeping in the shade.
Now in the late afternoon, the pack comes
together ready to go out hunting.
The perfect time for Jessica Watermeyer to
check up on the pack.
She heads up a conservation project for wild
dogs in the Savé Valley Conservancy.
It's a protected area that covers 3000 square
kilometers.
She's spent years working with these animals.
This is our festive pack.
We've called them that because as you can
see they've got beautiful, very distinct and
colorful markings.
They also happen to be one of the biggest
packs in the conservancy.
There are about 11 adults now.
Started off the denning season, or the year,
with twelve.
They had 14 puppies but we're down to seven
now and they're also obviously a very relaxed
and habituated pack as you can see.
So fantastic for us working with them and
for monitoring and research purposes.
Wild dogs are among the most endangered carnivores
in Africa, with population numbers of around
seven thousand at most.
The Savé Valley Conservancy provides a large
area for them to roam freely, which is exactly
what they need to survive.
Impala Antelopes are their first choice of
prey.
"They are incredibly social pack animals.
Just the way they interact with each other,
the way they take care of each other, the
way they take care of the puppies, how all
pack members pull together to look after each
other - very different from other social carnivores
for example lions.
When wild dogs had a kill the adults will
let the puppies eat first.
They will look after the injured.
They will take meat back to the injured."
The Savé Conservancy was originally formed
from an amalgamation of large private ranches.
It finances itself through tourism and controlled
sustainable hunting.
This means endangered species are protected
and the area is not sacrificed for farmland.
Outside the conservancy, little of the original
bush remains.
The local population has grown, and more and
more land has gone over to farming, leading
to increased contact between wildlife and
humans.
The conservationists now work closely with
the local communities to protect the animals.
Victor Chibaya teaches school students about
how the wild animals live.
He and his team visit the schools three times
a year.
Many of the children are fascinated.
The local villagers often have a very different
take on how to deal with the wildlife in their
area.
The traditional knowledge around the conservancy
is, basically, they normally chase them away
if they are predators but if they are herbivores
they normally kill them for meat.
So the knowledge which we are bringing now,
the scientific one, is, "No, we have to coexist
with even the large carnivores and also the
prey species as well."
Chibaya teaches the children about the food
chain - and explains what happens when one
species dies out completely.
The idea is to help the children see the importance
of conservation.
I think it's great to learn about protecting
the animals.
And now I know that if poachers come I need
to report it to the police or my teachers.
The wild dog project also finances books and
teaching materials and even pays the tuition
fees for some of the students.
This school started working with the conservationists
in 2013.
Headmaster Elia Ngwenya says a lot has changed
since then.
You can actually see, that even if we see
a snake at the school as of now they will
tell you, "Oh, Victor Chibaya doesn't like
us to kill these things."
They say, "Please leave this thing.
It's there to live because it's very important
for the ecosystem."
Of those kids that have actually passed through
this school we have never had a kid who has
been arrested for poaching.
Back in the conservancy, the pack are hunting...
close to a kill.
But this wildebeest is a little too big for
them.
Still it provides good sparring partner for
the younger dogs to hone their hunting skills.
So after a little excitement, predators and
potential prey go their separate ways.
But African wild dogs are themselves exposed
to danger, even inside the park - as we discover
the next day.
Ranger Cain Kodzevhu is out on patrol when
a colleague contacts him.
"They found a carcass of a wild dog dead from
a snare."
The ranger immediately heads to the scene,
where Jessica Watermeyer is waiting for him.
It soon becomes clear that the situation is
even worse than they thought.
We got a report this morning that there were
two dogs that were caught in wires.
They were still fighting the wires.
So we rushed here as soon as possible and
got here within twenty minutes of the report.
But unfortunately by the time we got here
the dogs had already strangled themselves
and suffocated.
It's a senseless killing.
The dogs were not even the target of the poachers.
They set the wire traps to catch antelopes.
The dogs tried to free themselves by biting
through the wire, but the copper was too tough.
Worse still: it's the alpha male that's been
killed, along with another adult dog, the
best hunters of the pack.
The next step will be for our scouts to work
with some of the local ranch scouts and to
move through this area now and sweep and make
sure we can pick up as many of these wires
as possible.
Ideally you pick the wires up before this
happens.
The wire is almost invisible in the dense
bush and the area is vast.
But the rangers manage to find around 50 wire
traps.
Dogs are unique to Africa.
You won't find them anywhere else.
As conservationists working in Africa we have
a duty to protect them to make sure that they
stay here for future generations.
And they are a completely genetically distinct
species.
Once they're gone, they're gone.
The rest of the pack will stick together until
the juveniles are fully grown.
Fortunately the alpha female has survived
unscathed - otherwise the pack would have
broken up.
But with her mate now gone, hopes of gaining
a new litter of puppies this year now look
slim.